salut c'est hugo aujourd'hui j'ai une
interview yannick jadot le candidat à
gauche du pôle écologiste qui est menée
par le parti europe ecologie les verts
le principe de l'interview face cachée
c'est très simple le candidat fait face
à un écran géant sur lequel défilent des
émaux gilles appuyé sur le buzzer pour
s'arrêter successivement sur des émaux j
dont la face cachée va révéler
différents éléments qui seront à chaque
fois le point de départ de questions de
fond sur son programme et sur sa vision
de la france yannick jadot en
l'occurrence a été directeur des
campagnes de l'omg de défense de
l'environnement greenpeace de 2002 à
2008 il était candidat à la
présidentielle en 2017 avant de se
retirer pour rejoindre la candidature du
socialiste benoît hamon il est
actuellement député européen voilà donc
pour la présentation rapide n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner évidemment à cette
chaîne youtube pour découvrir les autres
interviews des candidats ou encore les
présentations de programmes sur mon
compte instagram on va aussi à poster
des comparaisons des positions des
candidats sur différentes thématiques le
nom du compte instagram c'est hugo
décrypte je vous laisse avec l'interview
bonjour et yannick jadot bonjour merci
beaucoup déjà d'avoir accepté mon
invitation
on va commencer du coup avec la première
question la roue tourne je voulais
s'appuyer quand vous le souhaitez ça va
s'arrêter c'est une première question
alors ça en l'occurrence les mauges
graphique et pour chacun des candidats
derrière c'était maugis graphique à
chaque fois un graphique va s'afficher
tout va bien je vous laisse donc le
découvrir qu'est ce que vous lisez
qu'est ce que vous voyez c'est une étude
dont qui a été réalisé par ipsos en août
2021 avec une question qui a été posée
parmi les enjeux suivants quels sont les
trois qui vous préoccupe le plus à titre
personnel vous le voyez la protection de
l'environnement arrive en seconde
position ce qui m'amène à une première
question on voit que la protection de
l'environnement fait partie des
préoccupations majeures des français là
c'est juste derrière le court navires us
et pourtant vous êtes le candidat du
parti europe ecologie les verts et
d'autres partis écologistes vous êtes
aujourd'hui créditée à moins de 10 %
dans les sondages au moment on tourne à
cette interview alors évidemment un
sondage c'est qu'une cartographie de
l'opinion à un instant t c'est pas un
pronostic c'est pas une projection ça
peut évoluer dans les prochains jours
mais comment est-ce que vous expliquer
ce décalage aujourd'hui je crois que les
françaises et les français sont pas
encore dans la campagne électorale pour
l'instant ils regardent la campagne
temps avec comme un show télévisuel avec
les toutes les idées les plus
nauséabonds de dehors les arabes dehors
les musulmans on va karchériser les
quartiers et je pense que petit à petit
maintenant des françaises et les
français vont entrer dans la campagne
électorale ils vont voir que non
seulement il ya un seul candidat un seul
projet qui portent sérieusement
l'environnement c'est à dire respecter
ce que disent les scientifiques
maximum 1,5 degré donc on peut encore
gagner la bataille du climat que il ya
qu un seul mouvement qui porte le
bien-être animal il ya quinze seul
mouvement qui porte y compris le lien
entre les différentes les différents
sujets parce que l'avenir du système
social notamment la santé et les
retraites la question du que vides qui
est aussi un enjeu de santé oms et des
liens avec l'environnement vous l'avait
bien dit donc ils vont voir qu'il ya
quinze seul projet qui fait le lien
entre tout ça et qui permet au fond de
nous réconcilier avec l'avenir en
évidence le chaos l'écologie est selon
vous c'est le vôtre mais comment est-ce
que vous expliquer ce décalage aussi
notamment avec les autres élections
parce qu'on a vu notamment aux élections
européennes que vous aviez fait un score
important juste derrière leur assemblée
nationale et la république en marche
avec un autre notamment important chez
les jeunes même chose aux municipales
étaient les premiers jeunes le premier
siège année c'était quand même pas rien
que le vote de coeur mai soit avant le
vote de peur mais justement comment est
ce que vous expliquez que sur les
européennes le parti fait un score
important pareille aux municipales
bordeaux lyon ou encore grenoble sont
maintenant des mairies écologistes et à
la présidentielle ça ne fonctionne pas
autant mais ça va fonctionner déjà un je
vous le dis je vous l'annonçais et puis
vous savez aux municipales comme aux
européennes les sondeurs ils nous
mettaient très largement en dessous de
ce qu'on a fait moi j'en j'avais encore
reçu le dimanche des résultats des
européennes j'avais encore les sondeurs
qui me mettaient à 7,8 et on a fait près
de 14 donc en fait les sondeurs on le
voit chaque élection il se plante quand
même beaucoup mais ce qui est marrant
c'est que le lendemain ils redeviennent
prescripteurs du débat politique moi je
fais confiance aux françaises et aux
français qui vous savez en ce moment
on voit les difficultés en termes de
pouvoir d'achat ça c'est un sujet qui a
beaucoup monté ces dernières semaines du
fait du prix de l'essence du prix de
l'énergie des prix alimentaires est
justement on va voir par exemple que
l'écologie c'est la meilleure alliée du
pouvoir d'achat parce que non seulement
on augmente les revenus mais on va
baisser les dépenses de logement les
dépenses de chauffage dont les
déplacements et ça c'est bon on va
passer à la prochaine question je
relance du coup la roue et je vous
laisse je voulais arrêter qu'on voulait
et ça s'arrête un cadeau d'ailleurs
peut-être un cadeau empoisonné en voir
concrètement à derrière c'était magique
à dos il ya une vidéo qui va s'afficher
à l'écran et dans cette vidéo c'est un
autre candidat à l'élection
présidentielle qu'on a reçues avant vous
qui va vous poser directement une
question je vous laisse du coup
découvrir qui est ce candidat quelle est
la question et après vous allez pouvoir
répondre
donc monsieur jadot on se pose la
question de comment vous allez faire
pour répondre aux urgences climatiques
sans toucher au capitalisme sans toucher
aux à la propriété des multinationales
sont aussi à la loi du profit on voit
pas comment c'est possible nous on pense
qu'elle est juste une écologie radicale
anticapitaliste qui peut commencer à
répondre à tous ces problèmes là donc
voilà comment vous pouvez faire comment
vous pouvez rendre crédible l'écologie
sans lutte de classe comme quoi ça
serait pas du goût du jardinage moi je
trouve que c'est très bien le jardinage
c'est très bien les petites fleurs les
petites doses of truth a toujours
surprenants comme on oppose la
protection de la nature et la justice
sociale lui dit que je l'étais à ce que
certains n'ont pas compris c'est qu'en
fait ceux qui maltraitent les femmes et
les hommes y compris socialement
maltraite toujours la nature et
inversement quand on maltraite la nature
on finit toujours par maltraiter les
femmes et des hommes donc nous justement
on fait l'écologie et la justice sociale
quand par exemple dans mon projet je
évidemment il faut dépasser le
capitalisme mais l'économie fall a
régulé quand on fait du par exemple du
bio
le bio c'est un paysan il a des aides
d'état il ad'énormes qui doit respecter
il ya un label bio mais moi je suis pour
que le paysan bio ils vendent sa
production sur les marchés par exemple
en cirque etc ou ou dans nos magasins je
suis pas pour qu'il vende sa hausse sauf
cause
donc les seuls à connaître la meilleure
façon capitalisme est-ce qu'il faut
sortir duquel faut dépasser le
capitalisme c'est incontestable mais là
c'est à dire le sortir ce qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'on voit
bien que le capitalisme aujourd'hui et
est un système un modèle prédateur c'est
un modèle à la fois qui fait de la
prédation sur l'environnement chaque
parcelle de forêt doit être marchandisé
chaque parcelle de notre intimité à
travers de données personnelles doit
être marchandisé donc c'est destruction
de l'environnement c'est la guerre de
tous contre tous et c'est la
concentration des pouvoirs donc il faut
sortir de ce système là mais le débat
qu'il faudrait avoir c'est s'en sortir
ça dit pas où on va c'est trop facile de
toujours dire il faut sortir il faut
sortir il faut sortir il faut être
contre la seule le seul sujet quand on
veut gouverner
quand on veut gouverner c'est de savoir
qu'est ce qu'on propose et donc moi je
propose une économie régulée
écologiquement socialement c'est à dire
que dans mon projet il y aura lé par
exemple la règle d'or climatique toutes
nos politiques publiques
devront regarder l'impact sur le climat
ça veut dire que total ne recevra plus
un euro d'argent public similaire à la
règle verte de jean luc mélenchon dans
l'hiver je ne cherche pas des
similarités je vous dis ce que je fais
c'est intéressant de voir s'il ya des
points communs avec des noms mais très
bien je vous invite à comparer les
projets c'est une très bonne idée moi ce
que je dis c'est que
typiquement l'impôt sur les sociétés
sera conditionné au fait de favoriser la
transition écologique de augmenter les
impôts ou d'augmenter les salaires donc
d'améliorer les conditions de travail
d'améliorer le statut dans les
entreprises de garantir l'égalité
femmes-hommes dans les salaires sans
conditionnera l'argent public moi je dis
comment on fait pour réguler l'économie
je ne suis pas simplement contre ma
responsabilité
de dire ce qu'on fait pour que ça se
passe bien donc régulation pour
permettre ce respect de l'eau de
l'environnement ces oppositions sur le
sur le sujet on va passer à la troisième
question je relance du coup la roue est
toujours la même mécanique je vous
laisse à cuillé
et c'est un téléphone va bien mais
derrière ce téléphone qu'est ce qui se
cache concrètement je vous laisse le
découvrir c'est un contenu d'une
application qui va s'afficher sans
l'occurrence un tweet aujourd'hui 28
d'un autre candidat à gauche aujourd'hui
c'est un put de fabien roussel le
candidat du parti communiste français je
vous laisse le lire si vous le souhaitez
pour commencer ce tweet
alors seul à gauche à dire qu'il faut
investir dans le nucléaire virgule elle
renouvelables déjà on sent qu'une petite
ambiguïté le renouvelable c'est bien
après je l'assument on n'ouvrira pas d'
usine sans cette électricité stable on
ne réduira pas le prix de l'électricité
sont nucléaire il en va de notre
indépendance énergétique c'est donc des
propos de fabien roussel oui je sais
mais vous deviez lui répondre je
mentionné sur twitter on n'offre pas là
dessus et après on pourra développer
alors 1,2 phrase qu'est-ce que vous
répondez il en va de notre indépendance
énergétique l'uranium on n'en produit
pas on va chercher au niger dont des
conditions qui sont parfois dramatique
donc nous ne sommes pas indépendant
énergétiquement le prix d'un le p r
aujourd'hui succès en construction à
flamanville direct il devait ouvrir en
2012 il devait coûter 3,3 milliards il
n'est toujours pas ouvert il est pas
prêt d'ouvrir et il vaut déjà 20
milliards c'est deux fois plus cher que
n'importe quelle énergie renouvelable ce
qui est dommage c'est au fond ne pas
regarder ce qu'est la réalité
énergétique aujourd'hui il ya dix ans il
a il avait presque raison les énergies
renouvelables c'était un pari industriel
aujourd'hui le photovoltaïque divisé par
dix en dix ans le rhône les zélés
l'éolien par trois ou quatre et ça donne
plus d'emplois je suis juste un avenir
où seul ne défendent pas l'emploi firme
dans l'actualité à ce moment il ya
quelques jours la commission européenne
donc
des institutions de l'union européenne a
classé dernièrement donc le nucléaire
comme une source d'énergie labellisé
verte en estimant que son utilisation
était indispensable selon la commission
européenne pour parvenir à limiter nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre car
selon eux ce n'est pas jouable
d'atteindre une neutralité carbone comme
on l'appelle en 2050 en misant
uniquement sur les énergies
renouvelables c'est une position en
l'occurrence la commission européenne
qu'est-ce que vous au départ la
commission européenne trouvé que le
nucléaire c'était ça la met il vous a
pas échappé emmanuel macron notre
président pour sauver le nucléaire a
fait alliance avec la pologne du charbon
vous savez celle qui supprime
l'avortement celle qui a une politique
ouvertement anti homosexuels avec urban
hongrie pour le gaz pour que chacun
défende les mêmes intérêts et donc ils
ont imposé à la commission européenne à
l'europe de mettre le nucléaire et le
gaz comme énergie verte mais qu'elle est
totalement quels avantages que vous
voyez au nucléaire s'il y en a non mais
je dis pas que le nucléaire produit du
co2 je dis qu'aujourd'hui on est dans
une situation où on a toutes les
infrastructures énergétiques qui sont
vieillissantes notre parc nucléaire est
très vieillissant on a dix réacteurs à
l'arrêt tellement il est vieillissant
d'accord notre problème de prix de
l'électricité c'est notamment parce que
le nucléaire ne fournit pas c'est
d'électricité c'est pour ça qu'on la
paye très cher parce qu'on va l'emporter
et on la paye très cher donc on a le
sujet c est ce que dans la dent
aujourd'hui on construit des nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires ou est ce que on
réduit nos consommations en investissant
dans le bâtiment ce avec 12 millions de
français n'ont pas de quoi se chauffer
convenablement chez les jeunes c'est
énorme le nombre de jeunes qui arrivent
pas à se lever parce qu'ils payent pas
donc il faut isoler et c'est fini c'est
le déploiement des énergies
renouvelables l'hydraulique le
photovoltaïque l'éolien la géothermie et
qu'on va parler mais et au fur à mesure
qu on déploiera les énergies
renouvelables on fermera les réacteurs
nucléaires qui sous types de viendront
signalement obsolète mais inutile mais
justement la raison pour laquelle aussi
ce tweet est assez intéressant c'est
qu'on voit que c'est un débat
y compris maintenant au sein de la
gauche sur la question du nucléaire avec
des collections toujours été pour qui la
quitte jamais de façon enfin le voir à
la lumière de cette élection
présidentielle avec des arguments
parfois qui sont donnés après on passera
au sujet suivant mais c'est intéressant
de voir ce débat qui a eu de beaux
souvenirs avec certains qui disent que
c'est une source d'énergie donc qui
n'aimait pas ou très peu de cases est
nécessaire que le nucléaire garantit la
question de l'indépendance énergétique
aussi bâclée du raj on la porte
notamment s'il n'y a pas de nucléaire
son uranium alors acquis son
indépendance énergétique la lanière
question peut pour terminer là dessus
c'est cette question de la stabilité la
crainte de sortir trop vite du nucléaire
et de se retrouver avec du charbon ou
autres avec les critiques qui ont été
faites notamment à l'allemagne en termes
de timing comment est ce que vous voyez
la chose de votre télé bien je vous dis
hein on met le paquet déjà sur les
économies d'énergie savez l'énergie qui
coûte la moins chère pour les français
comme pour le pays c'est celle qu'on
n'utilise pas et franchement quand on
voit l'explosion des factures d'énergie
on voit bien que cette politique
pronucléaire savez c'est cette politique
pronucléaire cas empêcher d'investir sur
les économies d'énergie parce que
fallait trouver un débouché à la
production et donc il fallait pas
investir sur les économies deuxièmement
j'ai dit on va déployer les énergies
renouvelables et au fur et à mesure
parce que on aura d'autres sources
d'électricité et qu'on en aura économisé
on fermera les réacteurs nucléaires ça
prendra 20 ans ça prendra 25 ans s'il
faut mais la france est un grand pays
qui a été capable d'installer son parc
nucléaire on peut être pour ou contre
mais quand on a voulu le faire on a mis
l'argent on a mis les meilleurs
ingénieurs les meilleurs ouvriers du
monde aujourd'hui dans le progrès c'est
autre chose qu'il faut faire il faut de
la maintenance des centrales parce qu'on
a des problèmes mais aujourd'hui la
principale vulnérabilité de notre
système électrique c'est notre nucléaire
parce qu'il est vieillissant et qui
manque de compétences et moi je veux que
la france ne devienne pas un pays comme
la chine et la russie
obsédé par le nucléaire je conçois comme
toutes les autres démocraties qu'on se
dit droit à ces lacs et du boulot seiya
clé de l'innovation c'est là qu'il ya
des entreprises locales c'est là qu'on
invente c'est là que pour terminer là
dessus pour bien comprendre par rapport
à votre programme c'est une sortie d'ici
candu claire écouter vu notre un début
notre dépendance vis-à-vis du nucléaire
faudra au moins 20 ans au moins mais on
s'adaptera le sujet c'est pas on ferme
et on trouve une alternative c'est elle
on met en place autre chose et
progressivement parce qu'on a quand même
des centrales qui sont aujourd'hui
dangereuse vous savez que la centrale du
blayais à bordeaux à la faye être
inondées donc elle est vulnérable aux
dérèglements climatiques on a beaucoup
de notre centrale nos centrales qui sont
refroidis par les fleuves avec la
sécheresse avec le manque d'eau on a un
problème de refroidissement donc notre
sécurité ça viendra aussi la sortie
progressive et puis un truc qui est
moral
là on produit en quelques années on
produit des déchets pour des centaines
de milliers d'années la question des
centaines de milliers d'années va
ressembler à néandertal
si on pouvait faire autre chose ça
serait mieux sujet du nucléaire du coup
on le voit qu'il est important qu'elle
ne rende la seule campagne
présidentielle on relance cette route là
je voulais s'appuyer
c'est donc un chronomètre derrière
c'était mogis c'est une question qui va
être posée un exercice qui va être
proposé à tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle concrètement
en une minute je vous poser un maximum
de questions lilesa de répondre par oui
ou par a lancé à ces différentes
questions j'en suis conscient ça peut
être parfois frustrant mais l'idée c'est
au-delà des questions on prend le temps
est le sujet là de pouvoir passer en
revue un certaine mesure de votre
programme plus rapidement en une minute
c'est parti vous êtes prêts le président
de la république at il trop de pouvoir
aujourd'hui oui le pass vaccinale
doit-il être supprimés oui faut-il
légaliser le cannabis oui est ce utile
d'aller sur mars non vous manger du foie
gras ça m'arrive assiste auriez-vous à
la coupe du monde au qatar chez vous
êtes élu non aussi
faut-il abc le droit de vote à 16 ans
oui est-ce que vous porterez la cravate
si vous êtes président oui les éoliennes
est ce que c'est moche non
habiterez vous à l'elysée si vous êtes
élu oui avez-vous déjà acheté sur amazon
oui faut-il autoriser l'euthanasie oui
faut-il interdire le nutella
tant qu'il restera l'huile de palme oui
ça qu'elles sont il est le plus
d'hésitation l'allemagne était le
meilleur allié de la france
oui faut-il placer des élèves les élèves
handicapés dans des établissements
spéciaux non
je pense qu'on a fait toutes les
questions à gtk mérite resté quelques
secondes et encore j'avais des parfums
des temps de latence de mon côté pour
les pour les poser on passe à la
question suivante je refais défilé la
rouge vous laisse l'arrivée
ça s'arrête sur
le cinéma cinéma on va pas regarder un
film drôle a vraiment le pas vraiment de
temps malheureusement mais vous êtes
tombé sur les mots jeux vidéo alors là
c'est assez simple une vidéo ce pas
s'afficher à l'écran je vous propose de
la regarder on en parle du coup juste
après attachés les mains dans le dos les
yeux bandés des centaines d'hommes
attendent en ligne avant d'être poussée
dans des trains
cette scène est filmée par drones en
août dernier au dessus de la province de
xinjiang au nord-ouest de la chine là où
la minorité ouïghoure musulmane subi la
répression chinoise c'est donc un
extrait de tv5 monde avec des images
filmées par un drone en août 2019 qui
ont fait le tour du monde on parle de
notre côté sur la chaîne très
régulièrement de la question des
ouigours vous avez dénoncé à plusieurs
reprises les actions de la chine
yannick jadot concrètement je vais vous
devenez président la république quelles
seront les relations entre la france et
la chine un faux pas la chine évidemment
c'est un pays qui existe est un immense
pays 2 déjà faut commencer à lui parler
au nom de l'union européenne la seule
façon d'avoir un rapport de forces c'est
moins important avec la chine c'est
d'être dans l'union européenne tous ceux
qui vous explique qu'il vaut mieux
sortir de l'union européenne sont en
train de construire au fond le fait
qu'on devient des vassaux de la chine ou
de la russie et là on parle et ça veut
dire donc leur parler c'est d'imposer
des règles commerciales économiques qui
défendent nos valeurs on va pas les
faire la guerre la chine en revanche
c'est notre combat qu'on mène etc
raphaël glucksmann et d'autres au
parlement européen un ensemble européen
interdire les importations qui utilisent
le travail forcé c'est la réalité dans
le casting chang et pas simplement parce
que c'est toutes les minorités chinoises
qui sont persécutés aujourd'hui deux
mois je suis pour l'interdiction des
importations des produits
ne respectent pas la liberté syndicale
on peut pas vouloir protéger les
salariés ici et jouer de leur
exploitation du réseau du mans si on a
une marque si on a juste pour mieux
comprendre cette mesure si on a une note
qu ils codent démarque c'est le cas
c'est l'interdiction sur le terrain
français d'acheter à moi je suis pour si
vous voulez le boycott des entreprises
qui effectivement aujourd'hui profite
d'une erreur de passer ces interdictions
par l'état là si vous voulez à partir du
moment où j'ai interdirait les
importations de produits issus du
travail forcé le boycott c'est plutôt
une stratégie de consommateurs ou de
citoyens mais l'aîné est ce que c'est
l'état qui interdit qui disent en fait
telle ou telle très bas oui est
interdite sur le terrain ce qui est
terrible c'est que si vous voulez on a
gagné au parlement européen le fait
d'interdire les importations issues du
travail forcé mais c'est que les états
veulent pas mettre en oeuvre je
remettrai les valeurs de liberté
d'égalité de fraternité de libertés
fondamentales au coeur de nos échanges
commerciaux parce que encore une fois on
va pas refaire la guerre la chine en
revanche la le marché européen c'est le
plus grand marché du monde et les
chinois seront budget justement c'est un
grand marché s est notre deuxième
fournisseur on dépend beaucoup de ils
dépendent aussi beaucoup de nous on
dépend aussi de notamment en matière de
dette ou autre il ya donc une forme de
notre interdépendance
il ya une certaine forme dans tous les
cas d'interruption a minima et qu'on est
dans un monde interdépendant vous avez
raison et le sentiment c'est que parfois
l'économie qui du coup prend le dessus
et qu'on est incapable de parler des
droits humains face à des pays comme la
chine puisque les questions économiques
prennent le dessus
vous ce que vous dites c'est que à
l'échelle européenne c'est possible il
ya une façon de répondre y compris sur
des sujets dessus bien sûr un sait
comment qu'est ce qui fait que ça ne se
fait pas jusqu'ici alors selon vous mais
parce que on mais vous l'avez dit parce
que ceux qui nous gouvernent mais
toujours les intérêts économiques devant
quand il ya un peu plus d'un an macro et
merkel célèbre l'accord d'investissement
avec la chine ils le font pour le
business en même temps que commence que
son diffusé ces images sur le génocide
des ouigours ou sur le tabassage dans le
sens et l'emprisonnement en question dès
lors été selon vous c'est une question
de priorité mais c'est aussi c'est même
pas efficaces du point de vue économique
ce qui est terrible c'est qu'il donne au
fond tout pouvoir au business au gros
business que c'est les multinationales
qui sont appliquées c'est pas la pme à
côté de chez vous qui se dit waouh le
marché chinois qu'est le quai lequel de
quelques l eldorado c'est le gros
business ce qui est fou c'est que y
compris économique mon le voit on est
trop vulnérable on est trop dépendant de
la chine regardez sûr on peut prendre
n'importe quelle industrie l'industrie
de la sidérurgie moi je défends les
entreprises en france plutôt que
d'importer de la chine on va en train de
fermer d usine de silicium si si on a
besoin pour les batteries électriques
pour les panneaux photovoltaïques et
vous savez le gouvernement défend pas
les entreprises françaises de silicium
et ovales importé du team john avec les
ouigours les bourses présent le
numérique moi je suis désolé moi je veux
du numérique européen je pars wei wei ou
les numériques chinois qui va contenir
les notes d'intention de marque comme ça
on bien sûr vivent sur les réseaux sur
le passé c'est impossible on peut
prendre l'énergie on peut prendre les
terres rares moi je me suis toujours
battu il ya quelques années au parlement
européen pour combattre le dumping
chinois sur le lit les panneaux
photovoltaïques il bradé les panneaux
photovoltaïques avec des subventions
publiques et les gouvernements européens
n'ont pas défendu notre industrie cd zen
de milliers d'emplois dans une industrie
du futur tout ça pour être dépendant de
la chine et leur vente des bagnoles
aborde un manque d mais un manque de
priorités selon un source de courage un
manque de volonté de notre souveraineté
économique et on voit bien que la notre
souveraineté économique c'est notre
souveraineté démocratique et on n'envoie
pas des ministres faire légion en chine
annoncée pour un boycott diplomatique on
a bien su bien sûr c'est quand même
incroyable vous avez vu comment teaching
pin et vladimir poutine ont utilisé les
jeux olympiques pour défendre leur
dictature et on envoie des représentants
officiels de la france c'est honteux
parlera t d'ailleurs en matière de
droits de l'homme de du qatar aussi dans
les abats faut pas les charmants avec
les voiliers de responsables politiques
non plus au qatar mais nous ce que fait
macron c'est plutôt de vendre des armes
plutôt que de faire respecter les droits
de l'homme 6500 au moins migrants
travaillent à l'émission des révélations
des médias guardian pour faire pour
faire pour faire des stades qui vont
être climatisé ce truc est dingue en
fait je voulais arrêter la roue pour la
prochaine question
argent argent avait avec des ailes
visiblement mais ça c'est des mots j qui
écrit comme ça on joue on ne choisit pas
très concrètement sur cette màj qu'est
ce qui se cache derrière je vous poser
trois questions sur des chiffres qui
concernent les jeunes sous forme de qcm
alors l'objectif je vous dis tout de
suite c'est pas de vous piéger ou de
jouer une forme de quizz comme ça
surtout que les chiffres peuvent varier
parfois au fil des années ou autre c'est
surtout de mieux comprendre concrètement
quelle est aujourd'hui la situation des
jeunes et après évidemment on va voir ce
que vous proposez sur chacun de ces
sujets première question à votre avis
combien dépensent en moyenne un étudiant
chaque année en transports en commun en
france je précise que c'est une étude
tirer donc une étude de l'unef qui a été
publié en 2010 est donc un syndicat
étudiant
pour moi c'est le plus haut parce que
même en ile de france je pense que pour
les jeunes c'est au tour de 32 euros par
mois donc pour moi c'est 302 alors on
n'est pas trop son dôme on n'est pas si
loin que ça parce qu'on est à 267 euros
pis en france parce qu'il ya déjà des
villes où c'est un peu moins cher qu'est
ce que vous proposez concrètement pour
défendre ce conte ce conte ce que font
les mr ecolo aujourd'hui c'est que pour
les jeunes yb est énormément
le prix voirie rendre gratuits les prix
des transports en commun donc on va
baisser les prix des transports en
commun pour les jeunes évidemment et
gratuit ou pas ça peut être ça peut être
gratuit ça peut être gratuit selon les
circonstances mais surtout moi ce que je
veux mettre en place c'est ce que
j'appelle un revenu citoyen automatique
des 18 ans dès 18 ans ça concerne tout
le monde mais c'est dès 18 ans personne
ne vivra avec moi de la moitié du revenu
médian ce qui est le seuil de grande
pauvreté dans notre pays c'est
aujourd'hui
918 euros précisément serait mauvais dès
18 ans c'est à la fois lutter contre la
pauvreté vous savez j'avais que les
étudiants notamment ceux qu'on appelle
les étudiants des cohabitants c'est
qu'ils n'habitent pas chez leurs parents
on est à 40 % de seuil de pauvreté c'est
absolument dramatique s'est les files
d'attentes convoi pour aller chercher un
repas gratuit donc dès 18 ans
automatique tous les jeunes tous les
jeunes conditions tous les jeunes à ce
sera au niveau du seuil de pour des si
vous habitez encore chez vos parents ce
sera un peu moi parce que vous n'avez
pas les mêmes dépenses n'est pas
autonome mais c'est deux choses c'est un
lutter contre la grande pauvreté
l'éradiquer dans le pays enfin et
surtout c'est créer de l'autonomie pour
nous les jeunes dès 18 ans ils doivent
être autonomes et pouvoir choisir leur
vie et notamment en ayant moins de
contraintes financières bien comprendre
sur cette mesure là c'est qu'on soient
étudiant salarié
ou en recherche d'emploi dans les trois
cas on recevrait cette somme d'argent à
la après ça dépend du niveau de revenu
c'est encore une fois c'est comme si
vous voulez c'est comme un rsa mais au
niveau du seuil de pauvreté dont
beaucoup plus haut et versé de manière
automatique parce que vous savez même
pour le rsa et à 30 % des gens qui ne
demandent pas parce qu'ils sont pas à
l'aise parce qu'ils sont sans domestique
comme agen donc là ça c'est automatique
si vous gagnez votre vie à 18 ans que
vous gagnez je sais pas combien 1500
euros par mois vous touchez pas le
revenu citoyen est donc juste pour bien
cerner c'était cette nature là c'est
automatique dans son sous le versement
automatique mais ce n'est pas tout les
jeunes à leurs 18 ans qui se mettent à
recevoir selon la csn
cependant besoins et ceux qui en ont
besoin c'est ceux qui sont à bacon pas
de revenus par exemple qui n'ont pas de
revanche mais est-ce qu'un étudiant par
exemple perçoit cette somme là oui si je
suis étudiant à ce que je vis à vis seul
oui marseille pour être bien sûr bien
sûr mais c'est bien l'objectif c'est de
vous rendre autonome avec
ça n'a pas forcément toujours suffire
mais au moins vous avez ça pour démarrer
ses c'est le seuil de grande pauvreté
moi je verrais indiqué la grande
pauvreté dans le pays on passe à la
seconde question de ceux sur ce petit
format là selon vous quel pourcentage
d'étudiants ne se soigne pas pour des
raisons financières là en l'occurrence
un chiffre tiré d'une étude de
l'observatoire de la vie étudiante
datant de 2018 est-ce que vous avez une
idée ah bin là aussi les chiffres
étaient énormes
moi je dirais 30% c'est 30%
effectivement même la question des
sujets en plus majeur parce que c'est
pas simplement quand on dit ce soit une
passe et pas simplement refusé d'aller
voir un médecin quand on a une grille
pain pas les plus sains que ça c'est
peut aller beaucoup plus loin que ça ça
peut être des problèmes de santé très
lourd qui vont être détectée très tard
et tdd
des impacts des dommages parfois
irréversibles c'est la question des yeux
c'est la question des deux ans et la
question est qu'est ce que vous proposez
père salah ben si vous voulez encore une
fois à partir du moment où l'offre enfin
geof se met en place un revenu citoyen
c'est évidemment pour lutter contre mais
attention nous on est pour la santé
gratuite c'est à dire que au fond si les
étudiants ne se soigne pas c'est aussi
parce que malheureusement parfois cela
la santé reste cher troisième question
et c'est la dernière s'est avérée avec
ce format en tout cas celle ci plus plus
direct on va parler de culture est ce
que vous connaissez le montant du pass
culture mise en place par emmanuel mal
aujourd'hui je sais qu'il a encore
changé là il a encore changé encore
changé à la dia qui comme il en campagne
électorale il distribue beaucoup
d'argent on veut dire 300 îles et 300
euros avec moins de 18 ans ça commence
plus jeunes avec des montants plus
faibles mais il est de 300 euros à 18
ans est utilisable pendant deux ans si
vous êtes présent est ce que ce pass
culture et juba femmes pour vous dire la
vérité pourquoi parce que on voit dans
l'utilisation du pass culture à cette
impasse qui est réservé à une toute
petite partie des jeunes au fond ce qui
ont déjà accès à la culture on se régale
accessible pour tous les noms mais la
question c'est de l'utilisation c'est ça
qu'il faut regarder comment l'utilisent
à c'est la partie 2 il est parfois
utilisé vous savez pour acheter des
biens culturels qui sont parfois
d'ailleurs vendu
site aussitôt acheté récemment des
mangas exactement exactement
donc moi ce que je le le système que
nous privilégions c'est au fond un
conçoit mois sur le soutien parce que
tout ce budget là il va pas aux artistes
en fait il en direct demain il va pas
maintenant pas non parce que quand vous
achetez un manga me dit je ne dis pas
que vous aider le groupe de rock le
groupe de hip hop ou de meta et dès le 2
h a été l'auteur du bien que vous
achetez ouais mais là le pommeau sais
que ça va souvent sur des biens
culturels et à l'étranger voilà qui sont
faits l'étranger qui renforce pas la
culture en france moi je préférerais que
à la fois on facilite les places de
théâtre les places de cinéma les places
de concert qu'on aide à travers ça les
artistes la création vous savez plutôt
que simplement d'aller vers la
consommation de culture qui exclut on
passe à une autre question toujours la
même mécanique commence à la connaître
et s'appuyer sur le buzzer
c'est un journal vous êtes tombés sur
les mots j articles de presse
concrètement via un article de presse
qui va s'afficher je vous laisse du coup
le lire et me dire ce que vous comptez
faire pour faire face à ce problème dans
le processus de recrutement qu'il ait vu
ici je vous laisse le lire pour
commencer à voix haute
un salarié sur cinq estiment avoir été
victimes
de discrimination à l'embauché un
sondage met donc en lumière la
persistance de discriminations à la
gauche sur 4000 26 salariés de plus de
18 ans 21% assure en avoir déjà fait
l'expérience les femmes et les jeunes
seraient les plus qu'on sait c'est
profondément choquant c'est une étude
c'est un article pour donner un peu de
contexte qui date de juin 2021 s'appuie
sur l'étude de l'ifop le problème c'est
que ça va changer qu'est ce que vous
proposez comme à mesure comment faire
face à ce problème dans le consentement
c'est abominable parce que c'est des
vies cd des ambitions des engagements
dès
qu'ils sont abîmés et c'est toute notre
richesse collective quand une personne
les discriminer ces sadiques et abîmés
ou la personne qui est humilié mais si
toute la société qui s'appauvrit parce
que cette triche à 70 ou diaz cet
engagement c'est toute la société qui le
perd donc il faut agir nous on est
évidemment pour la la généralisation des
anonymes à des cv par exemple c'est à
dire quoi concrètement en terme de
fonctionnement bah ça veut dire que
quand je vous répondais à une une offre
d'emploi quand vous chercher du boulot
vous n'avez pas apprécié et a précisé
évidemment mon prénom
là d'où vous venez parce que les
discriminations à ce fond sur le nom le
prénom elle se fond avec derrière l'idée
que de votre origine
potentiellement de votre religion ça se
fait aussi sur le lieu où vous êtes né
et c'est une maison qui avait été devait
être mise en place mais oui 15 a été
abandonnée le texte en 2006 on voyait
une loi dessus qui avait été votée mais
ensuite jamais un décret pour la faire
avant le traitement et ben nous on
mettre en place et il mettra votre à 100
places et deuxièmement
c'est pas simplement sur l' embauche et
simplement jouer sur ce point précis ça
avait été abandonné à l'époque parce que
l'idée était en soit justement on la
visite avait été votée mais c'est plus
sur l'application que ça posait des
questions la raison avancée à l'époque
c'était que le cv c'était plus le seul
instrument de recrutement et ça l'est
encore moins aujourd'hui avec linkedin
et d'autres plateformes et donc ce
n'était pas forcément facile à mettre en
place et par ailleurs y avait une
question de difficultés pour les
entreprises et dans les processus de
recrutement à devoir anonymisées tout ça
quand par ailleurs et bien la présence
en ligne fait aujourd'hui partie des des
éléments est ce que ça vous semble
applicable encore oui oui oui ça semble
applicable et y compris on peut
parfaitement faire vérifier les systèmes
de recrutement par
les salariés représentés dans dans les
entreprises pour s'assurer que la non
discrimination c'est bien la règle et
qu'elle a appliquée et deuxièmement
c'est pas simplement al embauche c'est
dans la vie que l'entreprise qu'il faut
s'assurer qu'il ya pas de discrimination
moi par exemple je veux mettre en place
le système à l'islandaise sur la
discrimination des salaires entre les
femmes et les hommes vous savez que dans
la loi française aujourd'hui si vous
sentez de victimes d'une discrimination
sur votre salaire vous devez au fond
prouver cette discrimination dans la loi
et sans votre salaire et on vérifie que
à compétences et à responsabilités
équivalentes le lâcher ou pas dans le
système à l'islandaise c'est beaucoup
plus intelligente et du coup ça va
beaucoup plus vite c'est que c'est
l'entreprise qui doit prouver pourquoi
elle met pas elle paie moins cher une
femme qu'un homme donc l'état accès aux
salaires ils sont en mesure de dire et
donc et donc c'est l'entreprise qui de
justifier les cas c'est pas le salarié
qui de règles qui doit au fonds réclamés
et du coup il ya un rattrapage des
salaires des femmes sur les salaires des
hommes en islande dont on veut
absolument s'inspirer la dernière
question
pour celle ci toujours jeune classique
je voulais s'est
appuyé ça s'arrête
sur un drapeau le drapeau français
remaniée puisque moi il est pas il par
exemple le sorcier théologie certes
concrètement derrière cette màj vous
allez devoir en fait reprendre la
fameuse formule de françois hollande qui
a été prononcée en 2012 c'est nicolas
sarkozy à l'époque le fameux mois
président mais de votre façon avec vos
mots et comment ça se fait comment ça
fonctionne c'est quelque chose que font
tous les candidats on a misé cinq
phrases le but c'est de les compléter en
une phrase est de les enchaîner pour
voir concrètement quelle est votre
vision de la france je vous laisse
commencé févier à faire des phrases
assez courtes sur chacun moi président
les jeunes seront et après je vous
laisse enchaîné - président les jeunes
seront autonomes
maîtriseront leur vie et seront des
acteurs de la victoire pour le climat
pour la biodiversité pour la justice
sociale moi président mon ennemi sera
les lobbys qui pourrissent les
politiques publiques moi mon premier
ministre sera une première ministre -
président ma première mesure sera d'
interdire l'élevage industriel je l' ai
déjà dit bon c'est toujours la première
mesure ça ça a du sens et ça n'a pas de
sens mais ça sera de 2 de sortir de
l'élevage industriel parce que c'est
toute notre rapport à l'agriculture à la
nature à notre alimentation qui s'y joue
genre aussi la règle climatique et on en
a parlé le revenu citoyen pour sortir de
la grande pauvreté et un dernier me
semble mois président les riches seront
mis à contribution pour renforcer la
solidarité la justice et la lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique
merci beaucoup aimé réseaux notamment
accepté d'échanger du coup avec nous
pour mieux comprendre votre programme
sachant qu'en complément de cette
interview comme pour tous les candidats
à l'élection présidentielle il va
ailleurs aussi une vidéo qui résume et
et visa à décrypter votre programme et
vos différentes mesures qui ont été
annoncées jours et on fera ça pour c'est
bien de participer à la démocratie on
essaie de le faire et encore merci merci
jadot et donc je me permets de tende et
du coup vers vous puisque c'est la fin
de cette vidéo je le disais donc on va
voir dans les prochains jours des
interviews de tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle
et le décryptage aussi de tous les
programmes des candidats ça se passe
directement sur cette chaîne youtube du
coup nous n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
évidemment sur youtube je ne sais pas
encore le cas pour ne pas louper les
vidéos les interviews les décryptages
suivant pense à vous abonner n'hésitez
pas dans les commentaires si vous avez
des questions ou autres prenez soin de
vous et on se dit assez vite